[Musique]
chérie Vénus a 12 ans et malgré son
vieillage elle n'a jamais connu la
chaleur d'une vraie famille cette année
la chance va peut-être tourner pour le
Noël des animaux organisé par la SPA
elle ira à Paris les 10 et 11 décembre
rencontrer deux futurs adoptants alors
Vénus est une petite mamie de 12 ans qui
est calme qui sait supporter la solitude
qui peut vivre en appartement par contre
avec un asc sœ puisque c'est un berger
allemand donc elle a des problèmes de
train arrière donc c'est une chienne qui
cherchera un foyer calme comme Vénus 400
chiens et chats venus de toute la France
seront proposés à l'adoption le refuge
saintapoline de plaisir emmènera une
trentaine de ses pensionnaires en fait
on se déplace on va justement vers la
population qui n'est pas forcément
véhiculée qui ne peut pas forcément se
déplacer dans nos refuges donc on va
vers eux et on leur amène nos petits
protégés du côté des chats le public
pourra retrouver Luna une siamoise de 10
ans qui a aspire elle aussi a une vie
tranquille idéale en appartement et pour
les plus dynamiques ces jeunes voyageurs
arrivent tout juste de Guadeloupe comme
il est difficile de faire des adoptions
là-bas on en récupère régulièrement donc
là ils sont arrivés ce
matin donc ils sont très mignons hein ah
oui donc ils étaient en famille
d'accueil là-bas et puis ils arrivent
chez nous pour qu'on les propose et
qu'on le trouve une famille en 2015 une
soixantaine de chanceux du refuge de
plaisir ont pu passer les fête en
famille grâce au Noël des animaux les
bénévoles espèrent un aussi beau cadeau
cette année tous les ans la SPA
recueille plus de 40000 animaux
abandonné